gentlemen Andy how are you very good you
know I wanted to talk about something
pretty important tonight yeah this is
big this is big yeah and when you say
something's big it's big big cuz you
tend to you tend to underestimate you
know this is this is a big deal I want
to get people all crazies but this big
this is big yeah that's enough thanks
recently I don't you've seen this
recently ABC has been airing an amazing
new series called making the band where
have you seen this thing I think a lot
of people have trick it's called making
the band and it's and it's where it's a
show where they're documenting the
creation of a brand new boy band okay
and the show started with a pool of 25
hopefuls and then the pool was cut down
to eight and it's soon gonna be cut down
to the final five guys and it's pretty
riveting a lot of people were talking
about it's actually a band it's gonna be
a real band and so you see these
people's lives are on the line it's it's
the greatest television show ever made
down yes yes anyway folks since a lot of
what we do here at NBC involves copying
successful programs from ABC I thought
why shouldn't I myself go ahead and
create my own boy band that's the idea
these fans are huge and I don't I don't
get the big dough here at this show okay
for obvious reasons but if I had one of
these boy bands that just beat it would
be huge 20 making machines yeah exactly
so anyway I decided to do this folks
here's the elimination process that I
use to get down to the final five boys
the pool of hopefuls began at 6 billion
that's right every single person on
earth was considered then I whittled
that down to 1,000 potential superstars
okay then I cut that down to the very
best 998 guys when you only have room
for 998 guys two people are gonna have
to go home it doesn't mean that we're
not as talented as the other guys I want
you I want you and I love you thinking
Valentine's in hindsight no I should not
have audition for a boyband with a
dramatic monologue you come in here
sprinkle but place with powder and spray
perfume and and and lo and behold the
place has turned into Egypt and you're
the queen of the Nile
okay well from 998 I picked my five guys
and then they were treated with me to a
rehearsal studio for a day of boy band
training okay guys this is it first
thing we want to do is we want to be the
best band in the world who the big bands
right now Backstreet Boys NSYNC what's
our name gonna be dudes of plenty dude
with the Z plenty with an I know why is
with an a because I couldn't there's not
much you can do with us in our heart of
hearts we all thought that dudes plenty
reflected who we were as artists and all
the kind of music we wanted to make what
are your names I need to know names
what's your name
Maddie J Maddie J we're gonna change
that that's what's gonna be J what are
you
DJ drew okay from now on you'll be Oscar
what's your name Dan Dan I like it we're
changing it for no reason
you'll be Lorraine what's your name
Anthony how about Tony B hey what's the
B for Bravo okay make it just be your
just be Judah Tony what's your name
kill Z what's head again Kel's Kel's e
yeah spell it for me
Keo alright negative Q cute yeah
q z cool now let me explain the
philosophy here you guys you live
together you're gonna sleep together
you're gonna shower together always be
giving each other your props and your
snaps alright hang off each other in
fact if you could pretty much whenever
you go through a door try and go through
like that we'll have the doors wide when
you're at a urinal I want to see RO your
arms around each other okay no yeah you
guys are there for each other you've got
his back what's your name again Oscar we
got to change that just be Billy Bo all
right
okay high-five each other as much as
possible even when they haven't done
anything to merit a high-five okay cool
slap each other on the back a lot all
right okay hug each other a lot no
kissing and you know Conan has the
vision for the band he said one thing in
music group does is songs and songs have
words
so dudes aplenty should also do songs
with words anybody what are the words
for a hit song baby baby great baby nice
alright hey what else what else besides
baby oh I wish
okay I wish I wish I wish
okay anything else we got baby and we
got I wish about this what about a song
called
baby I wish you were my baby baby babe I
wish you all my baby baby I'll make you
make a baby yeah let's make electric you
should
[Music]
[Laughter]
how do you guys feel about that
feel-good buddy I was pretty hot money
time Chacos we've got 20 minutes until
there's a step class in here come on
guys let's go this isn't a joke anymore
what was that what's your name there you
go
you're Ben from now on feel like it's
real electricity it wouldn't hurt if you
actually when you sang electric power
kind of act like you're getting zapped
by some electricity all right and you
guys look a little concerned for him
when he's getting zapped by electric
power all right let's do this
hold it hold it what's your name man dr.
W from now on and you get the name
before that big goal when you're ready
to say you're sorry for that
I wish you guys listen up this is where
we have to pick it up a little bit
you've got a fantastic voice okay rolls
beautifully alright but it's almost like
you're trying to bowl a spare why not
bowl a strike that way your next few
balls count on this frame Tony tries to
coach our singing but he gets stuck in
these weird bowling analogy I wish you
were my talking about more lateral spin
you'll get it to the center of the lane
that's where you want the ball fake
very nice job my friend you get a rinse
[Applause]
but the cracker I gave you okay next
time save the cracker
okay okay I think it's important to have
a reward system to get the most out of
your troops so I give them Ritz crackers
as an incentive fantastic and that's
bang and bang and okay again
okay you guys need a pose for you all
right give me the give me the wrapper
arms crossed
okay now cross the legs - nice I want
you to put both hands on top of your
head like you just got hit on the head
with a mallet look like you're hurting I
want you put one hand over your eye like
it's an eye exam the other on your shin
stick your tongue out like it you I want
you to stand sideways
turn your head completely so that you're
facing away no one should ever see your
face and you right there I want you to
act like you smell something bad that's
it that's the shot I want to see over
and over and over again that's your
first album cover it's your last album
covered when they don't know your names
you're gonna know that you smell
something bad we never see your face
something's really wrong with you you
got hit on the head and you've got you
have to go to the bathroom one of the
things the Backstreet Boys have that we
don't have is a member with an edge look
at this guy AJ he's got the mad glasses
he's got crazy pirate earrings and look
at this cane he actually carries a cane
his legs are fine he doesn't need it
it's called a vanity cane well I want to
do one better than a vanity cane I'm
gonna put one of you guys on a vanity
respirator
[Music]
please me pee
yo
Samantha
and the kid man
guys also called dudes aplenty
[Music]
[Music]
hey babe
I wish you were my baby
I'll make you make a baby
electric
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
dude the plane will take a break we'll
be right back
Matt Lauer is gonna be with us in a
second